do you want to hear a story about the  wild  Annagh  I'm Sheriff Alan Cooper I'm the one who  found you you're gonna be with me until  you identify any relatives that you  might have she's a girl that was kept in  her father's attic can we close it the  wildling  what's the wildling does your dad tell  you that and so are his pals he ate all  the other children you're the last one  left have you ever seen a wildling in my  dreams it's okay you're safe here  we detected a high concentration for the  Pirela in her system  whoever did this wants to slow down her  maturity  [Music]  I really need to know did someone hurt  you  she's asking too many questions  what happened last night I want to help  you what is a wildling ana learn from  the town said they got every last order  but that isn't quite true is it  [Music]  you're the last one left  [Music]  you  you